See, now I want the audience to notice
I'm going to every passage using it to
show his God is fake. Because Jesus the
most high and his God doesn't exist. Now
you just said because the father said to
be the one God and that shows that Jesus
isn't God because he's the one Lord. All
right. Now I want to see if you can
answer this. I'm going with your
passages. When it says of whom are all
things, does that imply that all
creation came from God the Father? What
is all things here?
>> Yeah. So when it says, "But to us there
is but one God, the Father of whom are
all things, and we in him, and one Lord,
Yahawasha Mashiach, by whom are all
things." The of whom means the father is
the one that told Christ what to do. And
he went and did it. That's why there's a
differentiation to where they say it.
And so you see, Christ will always say,
"The works I do are from the father." So
it's through the father. And and again,
if I could just speak about agency,
that's how all
>> I didn't get the answer to the question.
Hold on. You kept preaching. I asked a
simple question. Does all things mean
all creation? You went on preaching
>> except for himself. Everything except
Christ. Because Christ was created by
the father. That's why he's the first.
>> Now, now when I'm answering you
directly, you're interrupting again.
This your third time since Cameron reset
it. This your third time interrupting
me.
>> Your third time.
>> Since you said all
>> I didn't answer. Wait. You I'm not
finished answering the question.
>> Yeah. Let Let him Let him just finish
real quick.
>> Okay. Keep whining. Go ahead.
>> I'm not whining. You're interrupting.
>> Go ahead, man. Stop crying.
>> Now, so the Most High, who's the ancient
of days, created Christ. That's why
Christ is the firstborn of all creation
and then through Christ he went and did
everything else. So when you're asking
did he create everything and I respond
by saying except himself because the
ancient of days is called the ancient of
days for a reason because he's more
ancient even than Yahawashi
and he created Yahawashi and Yahawashi
go and does everything else. You have
the floor. Notice again how he ran to
Colossians 1:15. I mean, every verse he
quotes, he thinks he knows what it
means, and I'll bury him. But I want you
to see what he just said because this is
his burial. That's why he's whining,
guys. He just admitted, "All things
means all creation." But oh, but except
Jesus. No, that you don't get to run
from this. Notice it says, "All things
are of the father and all things are by
Jesus Christ." Do you understand how
this buries this fake God? If all things
means all creation, right? Here you have
the father and Christ existing together
before all creation. See, that's why I
want to bury this guy in his fake God.
That's why he whines. It's okay,
brother. I'm going to I'm going to own
you, son. Assyrian. I ain't white. He's
white. All things are from God the
Father by Jesus Christ. All things he
admit here means all creation. How the
hell does it change meaning here? If all
things means all creation, all things
all creation from the father, but
they're by the son, that means the son
must have been there with the father
before all creation, which means the son
is not part of creation. He's uncreated
as old as the father. That's why in
revelation 1, he's the ancient of days.
That's why in Revelation 5:13, every
creature is separate from the lamb
because the lamb is not a mere creature.
This passage ended your fake gods. So
the father and Christ both together
brought all things all creation into
being. Just like the father cannot be
part of creation if he brought all
things into being. Then the son can't be
part of creation if the father used him
to bring all things all creation into
being. And that's just the first part of
your shish kebab because I'm going to
talk about the word one lord. One lord.
Now one lord
in 12 29. Let's see if you know your
Bible. It says here, Israel, the Lord
our God is one Lord. Do you know what
the Greek words for one Lord is here?
>> And what what verse you get? Oh, I'm see
>> 29. Do you know what the Greek word for
one Lord is here?
>> Mark, you said that's Mark 12.
>> 29. Yes.
>> Let me just go there with you. Um, it
says, "And Yahawasha answer said the
first of all comm." Yeah, I see
>> one in the Greek because Okay. But but I
wouldn't I wouldn't let the Greek
couldn't stand as being the end all be
all because he's quoting the Hebrew.
He's quoting what the Israelites said.
>> I understand that.
>> So when it says here, "O Israel, the
Lord our God is one Lord." That's
talking about the most high is only one
which is what Christ for the audience.
>> Yeah.
>> For the audience, what is the Greek?
What is the Greek there?
>> Okay. I'm going to bring up the Greek
right here because you see again I know
it's Hebrew but the New Testament quotes
the Hebrew in Greek
>> and I okay well I'm going to show why
it's important because Paul is speaking
to Greeks.
>> Now I want to know what one Lord meant
to someone who's steeped in the Bible.
Here it is
>> estim
one he is. So my question is this. When
you say to a Greekeaking Jew, someone
steeped in the Bible who reads
the Old Testament in Greek, when you say
to him, is curious or kios is, let's see
if you're going to follow this. Then
we'll go to Colossians 1:15, which you
butchered. I'm going to go with every
text you bring up.
Well, we got if I could Cameron um as
he's answering these questions, at some
point I get to ask a question when he's
going.
>> Yeah, let's do let's uh let's get to the
initial point.
>> Yeah, I don't mind completing this, but
then after that, I would think it would
be my turn. But I don't mind completing
this though, just for the record.
>> Yeah, because I want to deal with
because you quoted this. I'm just going
with the text you're quoting, friend. 1
Corinthians 8:6. Now guys, follow me.
One Lord is Kirus. In case you didn't
get it, let me go back.
Because the New Testament doesn't quote
the word Yahwah. It doesn't use that
word. That's in the Hebrew. Okay. So, in
the Hebrew, it's Yahwad. Let me just get
it up right here. Is this it? Okay.
Yahwah. That's the Hebrew.
In Greek, when they translate it, it's
kirus is kirus is Lord one. So, so you
can see it. So I don't think I'm lying
here.
>> I don't think you're lying at all. I'm
just trying to get
>> Okay.
>> So now the question is when you say to a
Jew to a [clears throat] Jew who knows
the Old Testament and Greek is and then
you say
the one Lord through whom or by whom all
things exist. In light of the Old
Testament,
the word one Lord is the Greek way of
saying one Jehovah. And Isaiah 44:24
tells us that one Jehovah created all
things by himself. When you say to a
Greekeaking Jew who knows the Old
Testament,
the one Lord through whom all things,
you're telling me they will not
understand that as being a reference to
Jehovah, the maker of all things. Which
means the passage you cited proves that
Paul is saying Jesus is the one Jehovah
like the father is the one God. It's his
way of affirming they're both the most
high. Refute me exactly.
>> So in Mark 12 and 29 when Christ says
and Yahawashi answered him the first of
all commandments is here. O Israel the
Lord our God is one Lord. And then
you're likening the word Lord here
curios to go with 1 Corinthians 8 and6
and said a Greek speakaking Jew. How
would they not see this as Christ being
a part of that one Lord? And I would
answer and say because they're not
Christians and they're not indoctrinated
and you fall on your own source. So as
you use Matthew's tw and 29 to show the
Hebrew was kiosk kios excuse me kios for
the word Lord. I can go to Matthew 22
and 44
and hold on one second. I can go to
Matthews 22 and 24 where it says the
Lord said unto my Lord those words is
also curios curios. So to the same
Greekeaking Jew, he would know that one
Lord is the most high and one Lord is
Christ because he know that it's a quote
from the Hebrew. And because it's a
quote from the Hebrew, he's not going to
be indoctrinated like a Christian would
be indoctrinated because he knows that
the word Lord has context. Because as I
said, if I go to first Peter's 3, 1
Peter's chapter 3, when it talk, is it
three? Yes. 1 Peter's chapter 3 and six.
When it says, "Even as Sarah obeyed
Abraham, calling him Lord." Anybody can
look that up. That word is also pitious.
So if we go by Sam's logic here, O
Israel, the Lord our God is one Lord.
When Peter is saying Sarah call Abraham
Lord, Sarah call her Abraham the most
high too. I guess everybody that's
called Lord is the most high. Everybody
Everybody you call Lord in the New
Testament, you definitely the most high
because it say curios that makes I told
y'all this is a semantic argument. The
Bible says if any man be ignorant let
him be ignorant. We are seeing clear
demonstration of that today.
Okay, [snorts]
>> now you get to respond and then I get
the ad question.
>> Okay, hold on. Now, number one, did you
notice he just again butchered my
argument? I didn't say the word
kerus. I said is kerus. You guys heard
it, right? This why it's recorded his
burial. This is after this. Don't show
your face publicly anymore, brother.
This was a decimation. I said the phrase
is kerus, one lord. Kirus is I didn't
say kerus. That's not my argument. When
a Jew like Paul reads the Greek Old
Testament and he sees in Deuteronomy
6:4, Zechariah 14:9, the phrase Yahwa
Ead translated as Kirus is Lord one. And
that phrase one Lord applied to Jesus in
the context of being the one Lord who
created all things. There is no doubt
that that means Jesus is Jehovah.
Because here in Isaiah 44:24
where it says, "Jhovah alone created all
things." Let's see what the word for
Jehovah is in the Greek. Thus saith the
Lord. Now watch, guys.
>> Wait, are you reading that again?
>> This is the Greek of the Old Testament
and the English translation right here,
brother. It's right here in Greek. Let's
see what the word Jehovah is in. Isaiah
44:24. Open up in your King James. Says,
"Thus saith Yahwh."
But now let's see what the word is in
Greekto.
Oh, there's that word.
And who is this Lord the that redeems
thee and who formed thee from the womb?
I am the Lord ego
that performs all things. And what's the
word? Panta.
That means a Jew who reads the Old
Testament in Greek will see that the one
Lord is Kirus is the one Jehovah. And
that Lord Jehovah is the one who
fashions us. And he's the one that
performs all things. Panta.
My argument wasn't the word kerus. My
argument was to say Jesus is is cirious,
one Lord by whom all things tap were
made in light of the Old Testament that
most definitely makes him the most high
God not the father but equal to him.
That's why I said a Jew because Paul is
a Jew who became a Christian but knowing
the language he applied it to Christ.
There's no way for you to squirm out of
this friend.
>> You just the very passage you quoted.
Let me make one point where you thought
proved your case buried you because
shows the father and son together were
there before all creation. Father and
son together created all things and
Jesus is the one lord one Jehovah as the
father is the one god. That's the
destruction of your fake cult brother in
humanity.